(audience clapping)
- Let's close out with something wild
we came across on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience clapping)
Artists use so many things
to create their works.
Paint, charcoals, clay,
even reclaimed objects.
But have you ever seen this?
'Cause I've never seen this.
That's Michael.
And he patiently uses the sun
and a magnifying glass to burn
images into a wooden canvas.
That's insane to me.
Check out some of his finished pieces.
What?
That's so insane to me.
We have Michael on the line right now
watching on Idaho News 6.
What's up, man?
You are so gifted.
(audience cheering)
- Hey Kelly, how's it going?
- I mean, first of all, you
have like the patience of Job.
I'm like, that has to take some time.
How did you come up with this?
- Well, I've been an
artist for many years.
I went to college for fine arts,
but it wasn't until 2012
that I packed my bag
and I went on a long journey
from South Korea to Greece.
And I knew that I wanted
to travel and create art,
so I needed to find a tool
that I could fit in my pack
without taking up too much weight.
And one day, I think it
was the day that I started
to realize I was losing my hair.
I felt the sun so beating
down on my forehead
that I knew I could use the
sun as a source of inspiration
or as the tool to paint.
So, I never looked back.
And it was at that point that
I picked up a magnifying glass
and I started to create artwork.
Some of 'em take anywhere
from one to 40 hours.
Oftentimes I'm standing
in direct sunlight.
Right now, it's 12 degrees
out in Boise, Idaho,
but it's sunny, so I could
technically walk outside
and create art, but it's freezing.
I could also do it in the
summertime too, when it's 120 out.
And as long as the sun's shining,
I can create incredible pieces of art,
like the ones you see behind me.
And I also get an
incredible workout from it.
It's something that mixes the beauty
of exercise and creativity.
- It's amazing.
What's your teaching method?
You teach people now to do this, right?
- I teach people, but I wanna preface
everything I'm about to say.
Do not try this at home.
I'm a skilled professional.
I've been doing this for years.
I've been teaching this
technique since about 2013.
And I used to go to parks and
the beach on my free time,
and I would set up,
I'd set up a piece of artwork
and I'd start working.
And behind me, I would have a crowd
of 30 to 40 people gathering,
asking me how I did this.
So I said here,
and I'd pull out a magnifying glass,
a pair of protective eyewear,
and a hat, which I provided for everybody.
And I taught them how they too
can create art with the sun.
And so, you know, despite the patience,
I think the most fundamental
part of the whole thing
is it teaches and inspires children.
The magic behind it.
The magic behind the power of the sun,
which it's truth and it's
real and it's guidance
and it's patience and it's respect.
And for children, to see
the gleam in their eye
that what they're witnessing is magic.
And for me to tell them,
"Hey, this is truth."
It's not a rabbit in a hat trick.
- Yeah.
- This is the power of
the sun in your hand.
- That is so magical.
You just made it way cooler
just with that explanation,
you should write a children's book.
I was like, what?
Thank you so much, Michael.
This is so inspiring.
Like what you do, it's so
different, creatively speaking,
and what dedication it
takes is incredible.
I'm liking your post right now, all right.
- [Michael] Thank you so much, Kelly,
for having me on your show.
- Absolutely.
Thank you for creating such beautiful art.
I mean, that's not all, my man.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Precise the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable artists
just like yourself, sir.
So, they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How's that sound?
- No way.
Awesome, thank you.
- Thank you so much, Michael.
Have such a great 2024.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Sophia Vergara, Theresa
Caputo, and Say She She.
Have a great day, y'all,
and if it's not, change it.